what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have our
very first look at loki season two and
some behind the scenes photos actually
start to spark some questions about what
we're exactly going to see during loki's
season 2. now there are many disney plus
shows that have had an impact on the mcu
but i don't think there's a show that's
had a bigger impact on the mcu as a
whole than loki loki explained the
multiverse to us and explained variants
and explained the multiversal war that
already happened and is going to happen
again aka secret wars it introduced the
tva but it also kind of disbanded the
tva but then created a new one under the
control of king the conqueror and left
us with quite a cliffhanger at the end
of loki season one loki finds himself
back at the tva and he goes up to his
good friend mobius who does not know who
he is the same with hunter b-15 they
actually kind of think he's a threat and
they call security so if you're
wondering what exactly is going to
happen in loki season 2 well we have a
tiny glimpse into that today so we have
set photos behind the scene set photos
of owen wilson's mobius and tom
hiddleston's loki but first let's start
off with an interesting eternals
connection in some set photos taken by
the noel theater in london we see a
bunch of movie posters one of them is of
kingo the eternal now for those of you
who watch the eternals and for those of
you who haven't spoiler alert if you
care when the eternals disbanded kingo
made himself into a famous bollywood
actor over many generations of time and
while everybody thought these actors
were played by different people the son
grandson great-grandson of the first
original actor it was all just kingo and
here we see a poster with his face on it
this implies that loki really is going
to start to explore other areas of the
mcu specifically the multiverse and
different parts of time now of course
they did this in loki's season one a
little bit but outside of the first
episode and second episode we didn't
really dive too much into any connection
with any of the other films or other
disney plush shows but it seems like for
season two that might change just a
little bit and there might be a little
bit more of a connection here now right
before we dive into the pictures of tom
hiddleston and owen wilson there are a
couple of other posters here that have
other marvel comics characters in them
specifically of zaniac and phone ranger
now most people probably don't know who
these characters are they're not super
prominent characters in marvel comics
but their characters nonetheless zaniak
first appeared in thor number 319 in
1982 and is an entity that possesses
human hosts compelling them to kill
beautiful women and it's heavily implied
that this person possessed jack the
ripper and made him do all of those
terrible things and then a movie was
made about him later the phone repairman
has a bit of a different odd story he
was a telephone repairman who gained his
powers when he was called to fix a phone
that was actually a secret prison to a
race of aliens with advanced technology
the phone broke releasing all of the
aliens from the prison but they left all
of their technology behind giving the
repairman access to all of it so we're
already getting a taste of some little
tiny easter eggs that are going to be in
loki season 2. now moving on to the set
photos of tom hiddleston's loki and owen
wilson's mobius we can actually see both
of them very dressed up here now at
first we see just loki no tva agents
around him mobius is not around him and
there's not really much context to this
however i do have some theories of what
i believe could be happening here which
we'll get to in just a bit but notice
there are actually vintage cars around
tom hiddleston now these cars could be
collectors and they could be in a modern
time however i doubt it this is a show
about the multiverse and time travel so
i'm assuming loki has gone back in time
and based off of the other movie posters
that were shown in the other photos
since they were in london we could
probably assume loki in this photo is in
london as well and these photos also
show us posters for airport 1975 and
herbie rides again and both of those
were released in 1974 so we can assume
that this takes place in 1974 whatever
scene is being shot here so we have loki
going back in time and he's dressed up
in a tuxedo but we also have other
photos of mobius also dressed up in a
tuxedo in the same scene so the question
is what exactly is going on here again
when we left off with loki season 1
mobius had no idea who loki was and he
called security to come and kind of take
loki away so what happens from there why
is loki not in a prison right now in the
tva and why are mobius and loki both in
tuxedos here well we kind of have a few
options here and i'll tell you exactly
what i think is going on but the first
option is loki has escaped is going to
some kind of formal event where he needs
to find somebody or find some important
piece of information and mobius is
simply chasing after him and they both
have to dress up in tuxedos because the
event calls for that and they need to
blend in they can't just wear their tva
jackets obviously they would stick out
now that one is a pretty straightforward
answer to what could be happening here
but the other ones aren't so
straightforward the second option is
that they are actually working together
again the only question is is this the
same mobius that loki knew before and
became friends with or has loki
convinced this new mobius that we saw at
the end of season 1 that kang the
conqueror is in charge of the tva and
he's bad and has convinced mobius to
help him defeat him now this kind of all
depends on your interpretation of the
ending of season one whether you think
mobius is the same person his memory has
simply been altered or this is actually
a variant of the mobius that we knew
kang altered everything and yes the tva
is supposed to exist outside of space
and time however the ending made it very
clear that things can change and be
altered so those could actually be
variants that we saw at the very end
which leads us to our third option the
original mobius that we met in season 1
has somehow found loki or loki has
somehow found him mobius probably still
has a temp pad which means he can travel
throughout time and space there is a
possibility that he has found loki or
loki has found him and now the two of
them are on a quest to stop king the
conqueror overthrow his rule of the
multiverse essentially now or a new
sacred timeline that he could have
created and kind of stop the multiversal
war but keep in mind loki is the person
who knows everything yes it was revealed
to mobius that he was a variant and his
eyes were open to what the tva truly was
but loki is the one who came face to
face with he who remains and he who
remains explained everything to him the
multiversal war and the fact that if it
happened again his variants were a lot
more evil than him and killing them
would essentially unleash them and start
another multiversal war now this
storyline itself is really really
exciting obviously loki season 2 is
going to really introduce us to kang the
conqueror and specifically nathaniel
richards because it all starts with
nathaniel richards that is the original
person who goes on to become king now
nathaniel richards actually exists way
into the future in which he then gets
his hands on a time travel device then
he goes back in time and continuously
just goes throughout multiple different
points in time and he goes on to conquer
a lot of these timelines which is why he
gets his name king the conqueror so i'm
betting that loki and mobius whichever
mobius this could be a new one or the
old one or the old one with a new memory
and no recollection of what happened
before which would kind of make him new
i'm betting that mobius is definitely
helping loki and the two of them are
trying to stop king the conqueror
somehow now this is supposed to come out
after ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
which makes sense because in that movie
they are going to truly introduce kang
the conqueror he's going to be the main
villain of ant-man 3 and he's also going
to be the main villain of the mcu for a
while and the events that happen in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania are
going to be huge they're going to
severely affect the mcu and it's looking
like loki season 2 could be connected in
a big way to ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania but also keep in mind that
there is going to be more than one
version of kang heck there could even be
a good version perhaps even iron lad
would show up but whatever happens it's
looking like it's going to be super
super exciting so let me know what you
think we're going to see in loki season
2. don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest marvel news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof